[music]
Ukrainians information that a noose is being prepared on the
Belarusian territory thanks to
these guys they warned us and
letter 6 hours before the
launch of the missiles
we discovered this Russia we have
to sum up what positions there
in the area of ​​the monster
to collect on these positions and after mine
there are no more attackers
intro intro so I don’t improve the
position didn’t see
[music]
Russia blocked the site and several
media according to Roskomnadzor
radio station Echo of Moscow and TV channel
Rain spread false information about the
actions of the Russian military as part of the
quote  special operation to protect the
DPR and LPR and the web pages of these media
contain calls for extremism,
violence against Russians and disruption of
public order
earlier, Roskomnadzor began to slow down the
work of twitter and facebook in the country
[music]
if full-scale in top knowledge
russia to ukraine ukraine europe to
radically change its position
ossiyan russian oligarchs and
based daydreaming and throwing through
european losev kai and dp.ru ranks shop
edge on waving cover tap
[music]